look at you Nikki yeah I've been working
out what happening there's no gym
situation go chest press no okay was
this for this movie or did you just say
let me get my life together be fine
no nothing yes a few things coming up
next they was like yeah yeah you got
some money you drop a dime what's coming
I can't drop it I'm be scared of it when
it come when it gets about you you know
tell me about that moment you walk on
stage today with all your cast mates you
know that this is the final installment
but people are losing their minds when
you guys just step back before you in
the same no it's fun it's fun and it's
good to know that the team are around
you you know who got now Miyake there
but days of ribbon Dean I thought all
the team meant for me it just feels good
for us to take in celebration sweet
though because you know that this is the
last installment and you're with these
folks that you've done so much I'm salty
he's got stank face you know it is busy
I mean you want something to end every
beginning must have an end but at the
same time you know we want to look
forward to our stuffing and it's not
gross to be had so important was it to
have carry in this one we saw the video
of her and you know I know the fans
really really wanted it to tell this
last story with yeah I think it's so
important not everything for the story
for the hope for the resistance for kind
of leadership within that universe to
not continue and confirm with Kerry's
character in a way that so respectful to
her and her legacy and in just ours in
itself would have been unfortunate so
the fact that JJ made that decision oh
my god do you think I have seen a couple
of a list collisions on this red carpet
with you already the rock Emily be like
this is a celebrity central I have no
shame by you know I love people out to
do my when it when they get into
Hollywood right they allowed to do this
thing where they like Isis if they're
not really moved by your colleague or
devil in films I'm inspired by all these
people and so when I see them I
appreciate them too because when I was a
little kid turning on movies it was them
and their role
that made me feel like oh I would love
to do that make me cry appreciate them I
don't answer it so cheer for Emily Blunt
in John boyega ya know I'm here come on
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]